WE ARE GLAD YOU'RE OKAY.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," TONIGHT
THE DISGRACEFUL RADICAL EXTREME
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY.
THEY HAD WHAT WILL LIKELY BE
THE FIRST OF MANY FAILED VOTES
TO ATTEMPT TO IMPEACH A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
WILL SOMEBODY PLEASE GIVE THESE
PEOPLE A COPY OF THE
CONSTITUTION?T.
WE WILL HAVE MORE COMING UP.
ALSO, WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH THE
MEMBERS OF "THE SQUAD" RAMPING
UP THEIR ATTACKS ON ANYONE WHO
DARES TO DISAGREE WITH THE
RADICAL SOCIALIST IDEAS.
THE 2020 HOPEFULS HAVE BEEN PUT
ON NOTICE.
EVERYONE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, YOU BETTER
FALL IN LINE OR A, YOU MIGHT BE
CALLED A RACIST, OR B, THEY ARE
KEEPING, "THE SQUAD," THE
EQUIVALENT OF AN ENEMIES LIST A
FELLOW DEMOCRAT COULD OPPOSE
THEM SO THAT THEY CAN CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THEM.
IT IS GETTING THAT UGLY.
"THE SQUAD" HAS ALREADY LOBBED
RACISM CHARGES AGAINST
BOTH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THEIR
OWN SPEAKER, NANCY PELOSI.
WHILE NANCY PELOSI IS POWERLESS
TO DEFEND HERSELF, THE PRESIDENT
IS FIRING BACK IN A BIG WAY.
JUST MOMENTS AGO, HE WRAPPED UP
WHAT WAS A MASSIVE RALLY IN W
GREENVILLE, NORTH CAROLINA,
WHERE HE HAD A VERY SPECIAL
MESSAGE FOR THE NEW RADICAL
LEADERS OF THIS DEMOCRATIC
EXTREME SOCIALIST PARTY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO REPRESENTATIVE OMAR BLAMED
THE UNITED STATES --
[BOOING]
FOR THE TERRORIST ATTACK ON OURS
COUNTRY SAYING THAT TERRORISM IS
A REACTION TO OUR INVOLVEMENT
IN
OTHER PEOPLE'S AFFAIRS.
HER COLLEAGUE REPRESENTATIVE
RASHIDA TLAIB AGREED WITH OMAR'S
CHARACTERIZATION OF 9/11 AND
SAID MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO
SUPPORT ISRAEL FORGOT WHAT
COUNTRY THEY REPRESENT.
CORTEZ SAID THAT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE MORE AMERICAN
THAN ANY PERSON WHO SEEKS TO
KEEP THEM OUT EVER WILL BE.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
WHAT SHE IS SAYING?
SHE DESCRIBES CONTEMPORARY
AMERICA -- THAT IS YOU, THAT IS
ME, THAT IS ALL OF US --
ASAN GARBAGE.
GARBAGE.
AND THEY ARE SO ANGRY.
EVEN YESTERDAY THEY WENT ON THE
STAND, AND THE ANGER -- THEY
WERE TRYING TO BE NICE, BUT IT
IS HARD FOR THEM TO DO THAT.
>> Sean: SMELLY WALMART VOTERS,
DEPLORABLES, PEOPLE THAT CLING
TO THEIR GOD, THEIR GUNS, THEIR
BIBLES, THEIR RELIGION, FEW
POLITICIANS CALLING OUT THE
RADICAL BASE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, BUT THAT'S WHY YOU, WE,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ELECTED
DONALD TRUMP DESPITE WHAT
NEW YORK, CALIFORNIA,
WASHINGTON, AND OTHER LIBERAL
STATES WANTED.
AND WHILE THE MEDIA MOB, THE
DEMOCRATS ATTACKED THE
PRESIDENT, THEY DO IT
COMPULSIVELY,  OBSESSIVELY, THE
APPROVAL RATINGS AMONG
REPUBLICANS KEEPS GOING WAY UP.
TODAY, NEW POLL NUMBERS ACTUALLY
INCREASED BY FIVE POINTS.
ACCORDING TO ANOTHER POLL, 49%
OF LIKELY VOTERS, CERTAINLY A
PLURALITY, BELIEVE THE
ACCUSATIONS OF RACISM AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP ARE NOTHING MORE
THAN A POLITICAL PLOY, AND IT IS
UP SIX PERCENTAGE POINTS OVER
THE LAST POLL CONDUCTED.
HERE'S WHY.
LET ME HELP EDUCATE THE RADICAL
MASSES.
WHILE YOU MAY NOT LIKE IT, THE
TERM "LOVE AMERICA, LEAVE
AMERICA," NOTHING TO DO WITH
RACE.
AND BY THE WAY IT IS HARDLY A
NEW CHARACTERISTIC OR CONCEPT TO
THE LOUDEST CRITICS OF WHAT WE
CALL THE BLAME-AMERICA-FIRST
CROWD.CA
WAS IT RACIST FOR KAMALA HARRIS
TO TELL PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT HE
NEEDS TO "GO BACK FROM WHERE HE
CAME FROM"?
SHE DID THAT TODAY.
GET THIS, IN 2016, SCORES OF
CELEBRITIES, OTHER MEDIA ELITES,
THEY ALL VOWED TO LEAVE THE
UNITED STATES IF PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS ELECTED.
OH, YEAH, THEIR NAMES.
THERE IS NOTHING RACIST ABOUT
THAT.
THEY DID NOT LIKE HIM.
THE ONLY PROBLEM, NONE OF THEM
LEFT.
EVEN OFFERED A PLANE WITH CAVIAR
AND CHAMPAGNE, BUT THEY HAD TO
PROMISE TO NEVER COME BACK.
TONIGHT TO THE MEDIA MOB ON THE
DEMOCRATS FOCUSED THEIR DAILY
ATTACKS ON THE PRESIDENT,
EVERY SECOND, MINUTE, HOUR, OF
EVERY 24-HOUR DAY, IT'S ONE
PATHETIC LAST DITCH EFFORT TO
TAKE THE PRESIDENT DOWN.
THEY STILL HAVE NOT ACCEPTED THE
2016 ELECTION RESULTS OF WE, THE
PEOPLE.
THE NINE MONTH FBI
INVESTIGATION, WE'LL USE THE
WORDS OF LISA PAGE, NOTHING.
THEY FOUND NOTHING.
PETER STRZOK, NO THERE-THERE
AS IT RELATES TO CONCLUSION,
CONSPIRACY TO CONSPIRE WITH
RUSSIA.O
BIPARTISAN SENATE INVESTIGATION
COME AS A RESULT, NOTHING.
THE HOUSE INVESTIGATION,
NOTHING.
MUELLER CONCLUDED NO CONSPIRACY
AT ALL WITH RUSSIA, NOR
COLLUSION.
AND OF COURSE, NO OBSTRUCTION AS
PER THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL.
SO THE PHANTOM CHARGES OF
OBSTRUCTION AND COLLUSION ALL
FELL SHORT.
AND THE LIKELIHOOD IS THAT ONE
WEEK FROM TONIGHT -- I AM
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS --
WHEN MUELLER TESTIFIES BEFORE
CONGRESS, AND I WOULD EVENY ARGE
AT THIS MOMENT, IF HE IS FILTHYS
ENOUGH TO TESTIFY BEFORE
CONGRESS, HE WILL HAVE TO ANSWER
REAL QUESTIONS FROM REAL
REPUBLICANS, THE ODDS ARE VERY
HIGH THAT IT WILL BE ANOTHER
BOOMERANG AGAINST THE DEMOCRATS.
EVEN IF DEVIN NUNES IS RIGHT,
THEY ARE LIKELY COORDINATING
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO SAY AND
HOW HE WILL RESPOND.
WHY DO I SUSPECT THAT THEY WOULD
DO SOMETHING LIKESP THAT?
NOW WHAT DO DEMOCRATS HAVE LEFT
IN THEIR PLAYBOOK?
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
THAT IS A DUD.
OBSTRUCTION, OBSTRUCTION, A DUD.
OKAY, WE'LL TRY RACISM, RACISM?
THAT WILL BE A DUD TOO, USE THE
PLAYBOOK THAT THEY USE IN EVERY
SINGLE ELECTIONUD SEASON.
BUT IT IS NOT EVERY TWO AND FOUR
YEARS ANYMORE.
AS I HAVE LAID OUT AND TO SHOW
YOU AD AFTER AD AFTER AD.
NO, IT IS EVERY DAY NOW.
YOU HAVE HYSTERIA BOILING A OVE.
THE DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN AL
GREEN, HE ACTUALLY LAUNCHED WHAT
WAS THE FIRST OF PROBABLY MANY
PATHETIC ATTEMPT TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT, WAS SOUNDLY DEFEATED
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
THIS IS A NATIONALEN
EMBARRASSMENT.
WILL SOMEBODY PLEASE GET THESE
RADICAL DEMOCRATS A
CONSTITUTION?
AND TELL THEM TO READ IT?
IF NOT MAYBE WE CAN HAVE
SOMEBODY READ IT FOR THEM.
WHENEVER THEY WANT.
BECAUSE THEY CLEARLY DO NOT
UNDERSTAND IT.AR
>> I JUST HEARD THAT THE
UNITED STATES HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES HAS
OVERWHELMINGLY VOTED TO KILL THE
OVERWHELMINGLY VOTED TO KILL THS
MOST RIDICULOUS PROJECT I HAVE
EVER BEEN INVOLVED IN, THE
THAT -- ON IMPEACHMENT.
I WANT TO THANK THOSE DEMOCRATS,
BECAUSE MANY OF THEM VOTED FOR
US.US
THE VOTE WAS A TOTALLY LOPSIDED
332-95-1.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN GREEN IS
DOING THE BIDDING OF THE NEW
LEADERS OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
REMEMBER THIS FROM NEWLY ELECTED
CONGRESS WOMAN, REMEMBER TLAID
SAID THIS.
SO NICE.NG
SO WELCOMING AND WARM AND
INCLUSIVE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN YOUR SON LOOKS AT YOU
AND SAYS MOM, YOU WON, AND I
SAID, BABY, THEY DON'T, BECAUSE
WE ARE GOING TO GO IN THERE AND
IMPEACH THIS [BLEEP].
>> Sean: AND DURING AN
INTERVIEW TODAY ON CBS TODAY,
TLAIB OFFERED NO APOLOGY OR
RETRACTION FOR HER VILE COMMENTS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WHY WOULD YOU EVER APOLOGIZE?OR
>> FROM DAY ONE, I BELIEVE THAT
HE HAS COMMITTED IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSES.
>> EVEN IF YOU BELIEVE THAT, THE
FACT THAT YOU CALLED HIM --
>> I DID NOT DO IT ON THE HOUSE
FLOOR.
I'M GOING TO BE UNAPOLOGETIC IN
MY SELVES.
70% OF AMERICANS CURSE.
THIS IS WHO I AM.
I AM ROOTED IN WHERE I HAVE COME
FROM.
AND IT IS VERY COMMON FOR ME AND
MANY OF MY RESIDENTS TO SAY
THINGS LIKE THAT..
>> YOU DO NOT REGRET THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I'M NOT APOLOGETIC.
>> Sean: THEY ARE IN A VERY
DARK, VERY SCARY PLACE.
THERE ARE NO MORE MODERATES IN
TODAY'S EXTREME
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AS SOCIALISM HAS COMPLETELY AND
RADICALISM HAS COMPLETELY TAKEN
OVER.
EVEN LIBERAL NANCY PELOSI, THE
SAN FRANCISCO LIBERAL TREAT, IS
TOO MODERATE.
THE SQUAD IS CONTROLLING ALL
ASPECTS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S MESSAGE AND
THEIR PLATFORM, AND ANYONE WHO
GETS IN THEIR WAY OR DOES NOT
FULLY SUPPORT THE RADICAL DREAMS
IS ACCUSED OF EITHER BIGOTRY OR
WHATEVER, AND TODAY
CONGRESSWOMAN TLAIB WAS THE
SECOND MEMBER OF THE SQUAD TO
ACTUALLY ACCUSE HER OWN HOUSE
SPEAKER, NANCY PELOSI, OF
RACISM.
THIS IS NUMBER TWO.
TWO OF THE FOUR RADICALS
THAT ARE LEADING IN THE
HOUSE AND INFLUENCING THE 2020
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE YOU SPEAKING TO
NANCY PELOSI?
>> OUR TEAMS ARE IN
COMMUNICATION.
>> SHOULDN'T IT BE A
FACE-TO-FACE?
>> I AGREE.
RIGHT, RIGHT.
>> I AM VERY PROTECTIVE.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, SHE
DOES NOT NEED PROTECTION.
I WANT TO KNOW IF YOU ARE
TALKING TO THE NEW MEMBER, NOT
THE SPEAKER?
IF REWRITE IS A DOWN WITH HER AT
ANY MOMENT, ANY TIME, WITH ANY
OF US.
>> AS SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, SHE
CAN SIT DOWN WITH US FOR
CLARIFICATION.
THE FACT OF THE KNOWLEDGE IS I
HAVE DONE RACIAL JUSTICE WORK IN
OUR COUNTRY FOR A LONG TIME.
WE ARE WOMEN OF COLOR, SO BE
AWARE OF THAT AND WHAT YOU'RE
DOING.
>> Sean: PRETTY SERIOUS
ACCUSATIONG AGAINST THE SO-CALLD
SPEAKER.
REALLY, THE SPEAKER IN NAME
ONLY, NANCY PELOSI.
AND AS I KEEP REMINDING YOU, SHE
IS NOW NEARLY A BYSTANDER IN
THIS NEW RADICAL SOCIALIST
EXTREME DEMOCRATIC PARTY, R WHIH
IS WHY SHE CANNOT EVEN DEFENDY,
HERSELF FROM THEIR ATTACKS.
REMEMBER, SHE ASKED LAST WEEK,
IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO SAY, SAY
IT TO MY FACE.
WHAT DID AOC DO?
SHE WENT TO TWITTER AND RUNS OUT
PUBLICLY AND ATTACKS HER AGAIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOADING YOU?
>> YES, AND YOU KNOW WHAT, WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT, LET'S NOT WASTE
OUR TIME ON THAT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO TO HELP THE AMERICAN
WEPEOPLE.
OUR CAUCUS IS UNIFIED ON ALL OF
THAT.
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN, I
SAID TO THE CANDIDATES, DON'T
EVEN MENTION HIS NAME.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHO HE IS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DESCRIBE HIM
TO ANYBODY.
WE ARE NOT HAVING HIM SET OUR
AGENDA.
WE ARE SETTING OUR OWN AGENDA.
>> Sean: SHE IS NOT SETTING
THE AGENDA AT ALL.
OCASIO-CORTEZ, TLAIB, AND OMAR
AND PRESSLEY ARE RUNNING THE
SHOW.
THEY ARE ALL SUCKING UP TO THE
NEW LEADERSHIP.
THEIR BELIEFS ARE BEYOND SCARY,
IT WOULD DESTROY AMERICA AS WE
KNOW IT.
WE KNOW ABOUT THEIR DREAMS TO
TURN AMERICA INTO A SOCIALIST
ECO-STATE, KNOWN AS THE GREEN
NEW DEAL, BUT PERHAPS EVEN MORE
ALARMING ARE THEIR VIEWS BY SOME
IN THIS GROUP BEFORE ON ISRAEL.
AND THE JEWISH PEOPLE.
CONGRESSWOMAN TLAIB, WHO YOU
JUST SAW, ACTUALLY WROTE P THE
FOR LOUIS FARRAKHAN'S RACIST,
ANTI-SEMITIC NEWSPAPER.
SHE ALSO PALS AROUND WITH A
KNOWN BIGOT, HER NAME IS LINDA
SARSOUR.
SHE WAS AN INVITED GUEST AT
TLAIB'S SWEARING IN.
SARSOUR BLAMED HER BAD
REPUTATION ON THE "JEWISH
MEDIA."
AND AS YOU CANSE SEE,
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR ALSO HANGS
OUT WITH LINDA SARSOUR, NO
SURPRISE THERE.
SHE HAS TWEETED ANTI-SEMITIC
TROPES, AND WANTS TO ACCUSE
MEMBERS OF BEING IN
CONTROL BY "JEWISH MONEY."
REMEMBER THE PHRASE IT IS ALL
ABOUT THE BENJAMINS, OMAR EVEN
ACCUSED EVIL ISRAEL OF
HYPNOTIZING THEM.
BUT IN THE INTERVIEW WITH GAYLE
KING, CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR SAID
SHE HAD NO REGRETS..
SHE REGRETS NOTHING.
ACTUALLY BURST OUT LAUGHING WHEN
THEY ASKED ABOUT ANTI-SEMITISM.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> OFTEN TIMES THERE ARE THINGS
THAT YOU MIGHT SAY THAT MIGHT
NOT HOLD WEIGHT FOR YOU, BUT THE
WAY THAT WE HEAR AND CONSUME
INFORMATION IS VERY DIFFERENT
THAN HOW THE NEXT PERSON MIGHT.
>> SO YOU DON'T REGRET YOUR
WORDS EITHER?
>> I DO NOT.
>> YOU ARE NOT ANTI-SEMITIC?
>> OH, CERTAINLY NOT.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR?
>> NOTHING I SAID, AT LEAST TO
ME, WAS MEANT TO BE FOR THAT
PURPOSE.
>> Sean: AT LEAST TO ME.
OKAY, WELL, YES, NO,
ANTI-SEMITISM.
NO LAUGHING MATTER, NEITHER IS
AL QAEDA OR THE WAY AMERICANS
TALK ABOUT THOSE THAT KILLED
3,000 OF OUR FELLOW AMERICANS ON
9/11.
OR THE TERRORIST GROUP
HEZBOLLAH.
YET CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR THINKSS
THAT TO BE SOMEWHAT FUNNY AS WE
PREVIOUSLY HAVE PLAYED ON THE
PROGRAM.
HER BEHAVIOR, OBVIOUS BELIEFS,
ARE PRETTY VILE, PRETTY V
SICKENING.
OMAR PLANS TO INTRODUCE THE
RESOLUTION FOR HER SUPPORT ON
THE ANTI-SEMITIC BDS MOVEMENT
WHICH IS A BOYCOTT ALL THINGS
ISRAEL.
AND OMAR AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
HER SQUAD ARE NOW THE PERFECT
REPRESENTATION OF TODAY'S
TWO-FACED DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BUILT ON SELECTIVE AND PHONY AND
FEIGNED MORAL OUTRAGE.
EACH WEEK THEY CALL TRUMP, OTHER
REPUBLICANS, RACIST, SEXIST, YOU
HEKNOW THE ROUTINE.
YET NO OUTRAGE OVER OMAR'S
VIRULENT ANTI-SEMITISM.
NO CONCERN OVER TLAIB'S WORK IN
FARAKKHAN'S PAPER.
MEANWHILE DEMOCRATIC
RALPH NORTHAM, THE GOVERNOR OF
THE COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA, IS
SLEEPING PEACEFULLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION AFTER HIS
FELLOW DEMOCRATS DID NOT SEEM TO
CARE THAT HE DRESSED UP EITHER
IN BLACKFACE OR A KU KLUX KLAN
OUTFIT.
I WONDER IF DONALD TRUMP DID
THAT, HOW THEY WOULD REACT.
2020 DEMOCRATS ARE KISSING THE
RING OF AL SHARPTON, KNOWN FOR
ANTI-SEMITIC, BIGOTED LANGUAGE.
WE PLAYED A LOT OF IT LAST NIGH
NIGHT.
HILLARY CLINTON'S MENTOR, HER
MENTOR, ROBERT BYRD,EN USED TO E
IN THE KU KLUX KLAN.
AL GORE'S FATHER TRIED TO BLOCK
THE 1954 CIVIL RIGHTS ACT,
THE HISTORIC LEGISLATION.
LYNDON JOHNSON RELIED ON
REPUBLICAN SUPPORT TO GET IT
PASSED.
THE DEMOCRATS WENT THROUGH WITH
A FILIBUSTER.
THE LIST GOES ON.
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE TIME TO LIST
ALL OF THE CREEPY, CRAZY, SLEEPY
UNCLE JOE'S RACIST REMARKS AND
POLICIES OVER THE YEARS.
AND LET'S TALK ABOUT CHARGES OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
AGAIN, SELECTIVE.RS
FEIGNED MORAL OUTRAGE.
ONLY WHEN IT IS A REPUBLICAN OR
DONALD TRUMP OR DONALD TRUMP
SUPPORTER OR DONALD TRUMP
APPOINTEE.
REMEMBER THAT THE "I BELIEVERS"
IN THE KAVANAUGH HEARINGS, THEY
ARE NOWHERE TO BE FOUND WHEN A
DEMOCRAT IS ACCUSED OF
WRONGDOING.HE
CASE IN POINT, THE GOVERNOR OF
VIRGINIA WHO GAYLE KING
INTERVIEWED, TWO WOMEN, ONE
ACCUSED OF A RAPE AND OTHER
VIOLENT SEXUAL ASSAULT, BOTH
TELLING PEOPLE AT THE TIME THAT
HE IS STILL IN OFFICE AND I HAVE
NOT HEARD A WORD FROM ONE OF THE
"I-BELIEVERS."
KEITH ELLISON GOT A PROMOTION.
BILL CLINTON SERVING TWOHA TERMS
AS PRESIDENT.
WHAT ABOUT THE ISSUE OF RUSSIA
COLLUSION?
TWO AND A HALF YEARS OF
CONSPIRACY LIES AND A HOAX,
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DOSSIER PUT TOGETHER BY
A FOREIGN SPY WITH FUNNELED
MONEY, FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LAWS,
AS JOHN SOLOMON WILL JOIN US IN
A MINUTE, POINTS OUT.
EVEN THE FBI KNEW 90 PLUS
PERCENT OF IT WAS A LIE.
AND NOW WE ALSO KNOW THAT IT WAS
UNVERIFIABLE, BECAUSE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE NEVER STOOD
BEHIND HIS OWN DOSSIER.
I HAVE NO IDEA IF IT WAS TRUE
HE SAID UNDER OATH.
THE MEDIA JUST SPENT MONTHS
HYPING PHANTOM CLAIMS OF
OBSTRUCTION AGAINST TRUMP.
DID ANY OF THEM EVER TALK ABOUT
HILLARY'S SUBPOENAED EMAILS THAT
SHE DELETED AND THE BLEACH BREAD
AND THE HARD DRIVES, THE ACID
WASH, THE 33,000 EMAILS.
AND BEATING UP THE DEVICES WITH
HAMMERS, REMOVING SIM CARDS, AND
BY THE WAY, OTHER EVIDENCE, ALL
OF THAT HAPPENING.
SO WHEN YOU TURN ON CONSPIRACY
THEORY, DEMOCRATIC STATE TV,
EITHER MSDNC OR FAKE NEWS CNN,
AND YOU HEAR THE ECHO CHAMBER
AND THEIR FULL TYPICAL DAILY
FREAK OUT MODE, KNOW THAT IT IS
MORE SELECTIVE MORAL OUTRAGE.
THEY DON'T REALLY CARE ABOUT
THESE ISSUES, THEY ONLY CARE
ABOUT THEM IF THEY CAN USE THEM
TO BLUDGEON A REPUBLICAN, A